ça lui rendant sa non je me suis fait
chier dans le métro en venant à bon
compte après t'être quoi tout daltoniens
bac c'est pas une insulte ça va lui
piquer à l'autre jambe et s'ils créent
tant ils étaient débiles ou quoi quel
idiot et mongolien en quoi est ce que
vous connaissez le point commun entre
tous ces maux et bas ce sont tous des
termes médicaux plutôt anciens qui
désignait initialement des déficiences
mentales et qui sont utilisés
aujourd'hui comme des anciens sans
chercher beaucoup vous avez sûrement
trouvé pas mal d'eau qui concerne des
troubles psychiques cette fois genre
singles et areski iso etc
c'est bizarre quand même d'en utiliser
des noms de maladie de déficience ou de
handicaps comme injures ben je vais dire
ça viendrait à l'idée de personne de
traiter quelqu'un de diabétiques ou
d'insuffisance respiratoire bon mais en
réalité
oui c'est bizarre mais en même temps
c'est vachement significative de l'image
qu'on a et du coup de la place qu'on
donne aux personnes en situation de
handicap mental ou psychique
oui non parce que mental et psychique
c'est pas la même chose non mais vous
avez raison on va commencer par âge
parce que comme souvent quand on sait de
quoi et surtout de qui on parle vraiment
on évite de dire n'importe quoi donc un
handicap déjà un handicap c'est quelque
chose qui vous limite dans vos activités
et dans votre vie sociale dans votre
environnement
du coup un handicap c'est pas une
maladie fait les conséquences d'une
maladie d'une déficience ou d'un
accident
ça peut être de naissance ou arrivé au
cours de votre vie et ça peut être
temporaire ou définitif pour clients ça
peut être physique ça peut être
sensorielle c'est à dire la vue l'ouïe
et cetera
ça peut être mental ou psychique ou
plusieurs trucs à la fois c'est ce qu'on
appelle le polyhandicap et donc un
handicap mental
marc handicap mental c'est la
conséquence d'une déficience
intellectuelle qui elle même est la
conséquence d'une maladie ou d'une
anomalie des chromosomes comme la
trisomie par exemple ça peut aussi être
parce que le foetus a eu des problèmes
au cours de la grossesse tout genre des
lésions causées par une infection des
médicaments ou l'alcool ou au moment de
la naissance parce que le bébé a manqué
d'oxygène au moment de l'accouchement
par exemple et ensuite il ya tous les
accidents de la vie comme un traumatisme
crânien une infection grave et c'est au
bout du compte le résultat c'est que
vous avez une atteinte des fonctions
intellectuelles qui vous compliquer la
vie quand il s'agit de se concentrer et
d'apprendre des choses de prendre des
décisions adaptées etc et ça concerne
entre 1 et 3% d'entre nous un handicap
psychique
maintenant bon ça reste un handicap donc
c'est quelque chose qui limite la
personne qu'il subit dans ses activités
quotidiennes
sauf que là ce qui est atteint c'est pas
les capacités intellectuelles
l'intelligence si vous voulez là ce qui
complique la vie sociale cds difficultés
à adapter son comportement et sa façon
de communiquer avec les autres à
l'origine de ces difficultés gars des
troubles psychiques qui viennent de
maladies comme la psychose
schizophrénique notamment ou de troubles
de la personnalité
mais ça peut aussi être des toc ou la
conséquence de maladie neurologique
dégénérative
et puis à l'autisme est plutôt les
troubles du spectre autistique
alors c'est un cas un peu particulier
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu'elle
n'entre pas vraiment dans les deux
catégories dont on vient de parler c'est
un truc du développement neurologique
qui affecte le cerveau mais sans
déficience mentale et qui n'est plus
considéré comme une maladie psychique
l'autre raison qui fait que l'autisme
c'est un cas un peu particulier c'est
que les gens sont pas tous d'accord sur
la notion de handicap
même s'il ya des répercussions sur les
interactions sociales pour les personnes
qui en sont atteintes
il ya débat c'est un peu complexe donc
je vous propose qu'on en reparle un de
ces jours
dans une autre vidéo dans tous les cas
même si les causes sont différentes même
si les manifestations sont différentes
dans le handicap mental ou psychique
il ya une conséquence qui reste la même
c'est qu'on perd une partie de son
autonomie
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas la
possibilité de faire ce qu'on a à faire
pas tout seul en tout cas mais il ya
aussi une autre conséquence est la place
que ça donne dans notre société
et ça ça commence très tôt dès les
premières années ça commence dès l'école
en fait alors dans le cas de handicaps
lourds
les enfants peuvent parfois être
scolarisés dans des établissements
spécialisés
le problème c'est qu'il y en a peu donc
peu de place et les 19 banques doivent
être très longue pour les autres la loi
prévoit qu'ils puissent être scolarisés
dans des écoles traditionnelles avec
l'aide de personnels spécialisés des
auxiliaires de vie scolaire ou des
accompagnants deux élèves en situation
de handicap
mais là ce qui manque c'est le personnel
justement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle plusieurs milliers d'enfants en
situation de handicap notamment mentale
ou psychique sont privés de rentrée
scolaire chaque année un texte de loi
qui visait à améliorer les choses a
récemment été proposé mais il a été
rejeté par l'assemblée nationale à l'âge
adulte
ça s'arrange pas beaucoup puisque le
taux de chômage des personnes en
situation de handicap tous handicaps
confondus est deux fois supérieur à
celui du reste de la population
et là encore la loi prévoit que toutes
les entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
doivent embaucher au moins 6% de
travailleurs handicapés
mais c'est pas toujours respectée le
résultat de cette mise à l'écart de la
vie sociale dès l'enfance puis tout au
long de la vie c'est que ces personnes
on les rencontre pas et réciproquement
très rarement et que du coup on
n'apprend pas à vivre ensemble
du côté des personnes en situation de
handicap qui soit mentale ou psychique
c'est compliqué de progresser ces
conduites et d'apprendre à vivre en
société quand on donne l'impression de
piloter tout petit que t'en fais pas
vraiment partout et du côté des autres
mais je vous fais pas un dessin on les
connaît pas on comprend pas ce qu'ils
ont donc on en a peur ou juste nous on
sait comment se comporter avec eux du
coup la solution c'est quoi les aider à
trouver les meilleures solutions en
fonction de leur situation pour diminuer
au maximum les conséquences de leur
handicap
donc les accompagner pallier leur
incapacité
mais surtout les aider à avoir la
meilleure autonomie possible sans
dépendre des autres et leur permettre la
meilleure intégration possible dans la
société vous quand vous avez une galère
quand il ya un truc qui vous empêche de
faire ce que vous devez faire vous
arrangez pour contourner le problème est
vive
mais là c'est pareil vous vous souvenez
de ce que je t'ai dit au début sur le
handicap
bon on se remet handicap déjà un
handicap c'est quelque chose qui vous
limite dans vos activités et dans votre
vie sociale dans votre environnement
les causes des handicaps
on peut pas toujours agir dessus mais
l'environnement ça on peut et à chaque
handicap sa solution adaptée
l'environnement d'une personne en
situation de handicap pour lui permettre
d'avoir le maximum d'autonomie
c'est possible il ya plein de solutions
pour ça dans plein de domaines genre le
logement l'activité professionnelle les
transports les loisirs etc
et en attendant que le nombre de places
et de personnels spécialisés augmente et
que les propositions loi sera discuté à
l'assemblée
il ya un certain nombre de structures et
d'associations qui aide ces personnes à
trouver toutes ces solutions là comme
par exemple la fondation des amis de
l'atelier dont je vous mets liens dans
la description de cette vidéo un de leur
combat comme celui de plein d'autres
associations
en plus d'accompagner ces personnes dans
tous les aspects de leur vie c'est de
changer le regard des gens sur les
personnes qui vivent avec un handicap
mental ou psychique
ce combat là sur le regard des gens
c'est aussi évidemment celui des
personnes concernées et il gagnera
qu'avec nous toutes et nous tous parce
que les gens donc il faut changer le
regard c'est nous toutes et nous tous
quand on connaît la situation de
quelqu'un quand on comprend ce qu'il vit
est pourquoi il le vit ça dissipe tout
un tas de choses qui mettent des
barrières entre cette personne et nous
genre l'ignorance la méfiance la crainte
toutes ces choses qui empêche les gens
de vivre ensemble et pour finir si je
vous dis que l' oms prévoit qu'en 2020
une personne sur quatre sera concernée
par des troubles psychiques
à un moment ou à un autre de sa vie vous
comprendrez que ça peut très bien vous
concerne et vous ou vos proches voient
la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]